quel oiseau entreprend la plus longue
migration annuelle la sterne arctique
cet oiseau migrateur connaît chaque
année deux saisons estivales d'abord en
arctique où il se reproduit puis en
antarctique où il met le cap après la
naissance de ses petits en une année la
cité un article qui pèse à rennes une
centaine de grammes fait donc l'aller
retour entre le pôle nord et le pôle sud
cet infatigable voyageuse parcours
souvent 80 mille kilomètres par an en
2016 des chercheurs du royaume uni se
sont même rendus compte qu une sterne
arctique doté d'une puce gps avait
franchi 96 mille kilomètres en une année
un record avec ses ailes longue et 3
t.su sa morphologie est idéal pour ces
grands voyages la sterne peut atteindre
une vitesse de 55 km heure une altitude
de 3000 m mais au chapitre de l'altitude
ses lois à tête barrée qui détient le
record du monde cet oiseau est l'un des
rares à franchir l'himalaya il peut
voler à plus de neuf mille cinq cents
mètres de haut sans bouteille sur le dos
c'est que l'hémoglobine de son sang est
capable de fixer très fortement
l'oxygène pour accomplir sa traversée
loi à tête barrée profite aussi des
courants d'air ascensionnelle et de la
variation du relief